good evening good evening everyone uh
thanks a lot for for being here tonight
uh so we are really happy to welcome you
in singapore and also overseas because
we know that we have many
many different attendees from overseas
as well so thank you felician thank you
design singapore to for hosting us also
tonight it's a pleasure to once again do
this talk together and so together with
me today hola
thank you very much
and uh we're so pleased to to to do this
talk uh with you guys this is the fourth
one in um our series of uh crafting
experiences events
so today we're actually going to be
talking about digital place making so we
all know the global environment has
seen very immense changes over the last
years and even so rapidly with the
pandemic so to recreate in-person
experiences in community spaces uh
brands and creative are turning more and
more to technological tools uh platforms
um it is a reminder that spaces we
inhabit
or visit are not purely functional they
also serve to inform and enhance the
human experience and to connect to our
environments and each other so in this
talk we're going to be joined by three
such
experiential designers from singapore
and canada as we discuss digital place
making immersive design and the use of
digital tools for multi-sensorial
spatial experiences we will learn how
these creatives are using a mix of
traditional and digital tools to create
new place making opportunities and
experiences to engage their audience
thank you thank you for for introducing
the topic of the talk to tonight so
maybe on the next slide please um so
before we embark into this journey today
just to remind a little bit what is
experiential design and really why is it
important so the next slide
um
so here as we can see so the growing
dependence on technological devices
extensively changing human behavior in
day-to-day life so creating engaging in
public spaces with convention
conventional method is increasingly more
challenging because we are all with our
mobile device and that's also what we'll
be talking about today is digital
placemaking so
um in in here so the major categories of
experiential design exhibition design
marketing entertainment place making
place making and environmental graphics
next please
so what is exhibition ethanyl is this
hybrid of storytelling and environment
often found in museums and art galleries
um on the marketing side for sensory
experiences like times square in new
york like super famous gave the
marketing and product experiences and
launching next
so when we look at entertainment
concerts and events that are finally
coming back to singapore so these
experiences scales from small to very
big
um regarding the environmental graphics
so messages information on imagery
that's attuned to the environment that
is displayed in
and finally the one that we'll be
talking about today so place making
public installations and landmarks which
define the space around us
so the core component of experimental
graphic design signage and refining
interpretive and place making once again
so cyanogen wave finding those are
solutions that are more than just
cyanide joints like pathway visual cues
landmarks and so on so everything that
is surrounding us that is helping us to
move around
interpretive so this is something that
we usually find in exhibitions in
galleries so it is how we interpret the
stories about like concept and object
and so on and how we deliver this story
to the people
and the last one the one again that
we'll be talking about today place
making that creates distinctive image
for a site and can be expressed in
several ways so all of that provides a
certain framework
for communication and it is again to be
as engaging as possible and that
basically encompasses all of the built
environment
so now
your turn so before we jump into getting
to know our speakers a little bit better
we also want to introduce those who are
joining us for the first time or uh
reintroduce those or they're joining
again what is segd so segd is really
an organization that connects people to
place so it exists to educate connect in
and inspire the global community so who
are we what do we do and what have we
done this year last year as our series
of talks
so for the first so we are a community
of diverse thinking but we're not just
architects or designers we really come
for all different
ways of life we are multi-disciplinary
and we support design thinking in doing
we are passionate and personable and we
are about meaningful inspiration and
engagement we share along for design
so our first event was um on
environmental graphics and
refining design and we had such esteemed
speaker as kelly chang
you and arthur chin and william harold
wong from malaysia
in our second event we focused on
exhibition and interpretive design
joined by jackson tom laura miata and
lunai chyroporn
in the crafting experience number three
we focused on designing for good
experiences and we were joined by steve
lawler larry page and eric pajaya from
indonesia
so join us
uh communicate with us engage with us
and be a part of this regional global
community you can find out more about
our future events at segd.org
under the singapore chapter events and
you can also get started with the
membership under special southeast asia
rate which is a special rate um that you
can find also on sdg's website you can
access a members only resource listing
of podcasts and firm bios you
invitations to speak published news and
contribute content and you can also
receive multiple discounts on award
submissions event registration and
training
so so let us get to know our speakers
let's get to those speakers so david
olivier and cheryl
of course we will be sharing a little
bit more but then that we will do our
like now landmark a kind of icebreaking
moment
so like we will start with what we call
the fast and curious so these are really
like short questions to our speakers to
get to know them and it is something
fascinating curious so with much further
ado let's welcome on stage
they did come on stage
good to see you
cool so okay let's start next
so pen or pencil
[Music]
i'm gonna say
grayscale a crazed game
it's gonna be control for me
hello hello hello hello hello so this is
your turn let's take it away amazing
less is more or more is less
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll go for less is more less is more
digital or manual definitely ditch it's
all digital fast or cheap
oh fast
portrait or landscape landscape
immersive or subversive
for us yeah yeah immersive okay okay
powerpoint or no point no point at all
okay wonderful thank you so much
okay cherie your turns are all the way
from canada so come on stage virtual
stage so your turn now
there we go hi nice to see everybody
so linear or organic oh definitely
organic
simple complex complex
modular bespoke
bespoke bespoke for sure these are easy
okay temporarily
temporary
temporary physical or digital
digital i would tend to say
all right
and so okay thanks again sherry so now
we'll continue with our show and tell so
these are
longer questions well like just those
questions longer than the first and
curious and then so these are questions
that we will ask our speakers and that
are more about who they are the way that
they work the way that they create and
so so david i will welcome you once
again on stage
okay
so
um what is your favorite space to work
from
keep for me it's a little bit different
i i couldn't work in a singular space
for me i need to go at least two or
three space so if i'm at home it's going
to be in my bedroom
i have a workshop table if not i will
head on to my kitchen table in a single
day i will rotate around and if it's in
my office i will either sit in my
meeting table my workshop table or my
personal table so i i need to go around
what led you to venture into digital
i was involved in the digital scene
quite early when web 1.0 started so
it was very virtual for me so
moving on i was thinking can i bring the
digital into the fiscal space could i
give innate objects
meaning and smartness
and it was natural flow for me to move
from virtual to digital placemaking
okay okay okay so the last question
um
so the next slide so what is one object
in your office or room that you always
keep nearby when working
okay surprisingly it's gonna be the
trail
that's definitely because i
i do so much installation and prototype
and that is one tool that will help me
reach and finish my product quickly
thanks
so much
so next we will have olivier again to
share some of his insights about his
day-to-day
life and work
super so
so in in layman's term what's one unique
digital tool that's invaluable to your
day-to-day work
um
well invaluable for me i think okay it
sounds pretty nerdy but it's my apple
watch because it reminds me uh to keep
on moving you know otherwise you're only
fitting and working it reminds me to
stand up
wonderful
so what do you think will be the next
trend or the big thing in digital place
making
well the next big thing um well it's
basically reimagining our culture and
our
arts by really coming together online
um but more in an immersive and 3d way
think about web 3.0 metaverse kind of
style
okay and last question what is the most
unexpected thing that you might have on
your work desk
um i need to show it and you need to
show it
okay then then i'm in trouble because
it's actually my bonsai tree that i
really take care of to remember it's
behind me i'll grab it later so you guys
can see it i'm very proud
i'll bring it in
later okay good thanks oh thank you and
so the the last speaker so share with
your turn for our show and tell so to
also like share with our audience the
way that you work the way that you
create so share it um you can come on
stage for not only
but share it and do where you are yeah
if there's a bit of a delay because i i
don't know
because you're there
yeah that must be it
okay so what led you to venture into
digital placement
um so i worked for a long time in the
performing arts and i found it was a
really great way to um bring stories to
people and i feel that the developments
and technology have actually um allowed
us to bring this this way of telling
stories into the public realm and reach
a greater audience than you do in uh in
a theater for instance or in a
thanks a museum
um so on the next question so what is
one thing in your office home that you
always keep nearby when you work well i
actually don't have it with me but it's
my swiss army knife uh it's useful for
everything um you never know when you're
gonna need it and you know when you have
late night meetings have a little bit of
a glass of wine while you're having your
last meeting of the day it helps to uh
open the bottle of wine so i always have
my swiss army knife with me okay okay
and so how
has social media impacted the digital
peacemaking
um well it's funny because uh so many of
our clients say okay this has to be
instagramable right it's this whole
notion of shareability um and i think
that might bring uh social um what do
you say a superficiality sometimes to
what we what we do because it
or what the clients expect from us and
so
on on one way um and i'll talk about it
a bit later it allows a greater impact
in the storytelling that we do but in
another way it's a double-sided sword i
believe because it does um bring us to
this instantaneous shareability that
that that lacks the depth of i think
what real placemaking should be yeah
yeah
thanks a lot thanks for sharing this uh
this insight so thanks uh to our three
speakers and so now we will move into
the next chapter of our talk today which
is the one that everyone is waiting for
which is basically what our speakers
will be sharing about their
experiences their ieds their passion so
um in this is a very specific format
that we are that we are having so it is
basically 24 slide in 24 seconds so each
slide will last for 24 seconds so i i
know that the speakers maybe now i have
to do it how to do it so um
so so basically you will embark on that
but before this
to uh share a little bit about david
before he talks sure now is the time to
to really um
introduce our speakers um and give them
a sort of give a background about each
one's uh experience so first up is david
theo the chief creative street
technologist i'm sorry from insert coin
so david is a founder um
of the singapore-based company that
specializes in bringing interactive and
playful contraptions to retail fnb and
public spaces he's constantly looking
out for new and unexpected ways to
create magical moments to delight his
visitors some of his clients include
google hermes uniglo um singapore changi
airport f1 and singapore science center
notable projects by david include the
singapore world expo singapore pavilion
and numerous other interactive and
engaging works that were created to
mesmerize visitors and audiences so
david
get ready it is your time to tell us a
little bit more about yourself and the
wonderful stuff that you do
thank you
hi for the longest time i've been
uh
looking forward to making since young i
remember creating contraptions
that will make my friend laugh create
new origamis and show off to my friends
and then web 1.0 came i got involved and
created html websites they were very
much static
and i picked up javascript on the way as
well
and then
i bump into the website by
and he show us that websites could be
very dynamic and engaging i straight
away fell in love with this interactive
medium i spent the next few years trying
to master it learn it and after that i
could create interactive websites on my
own
and then came the maker movement and
introduced us a lot of digital
fabrication tools at the center of it
this 3d printer i got one i got so
excited because i could make anything i
could imagine and then i was thinking
could i pan making an interactive medium
together so today i brought four
projects to show what we can do together
with all these tools and also talk a
little bit about behind the scenes how
we do what we do
okay first up project
is this
space in
airport terminal 4. it's a viewing
gallery most of the time it's empty so
what we did was created three
projections on the floor to showcase
singapore cityscape singapore favorite
fruits and single greeneries
and then after we deploy
parents will bring a children and play
in this environment
behind the scene we decided to go old
school so what we propose to find is we
have a strong light source and we send
this light source through three
independently moving discs and in a way
we could create an endless scenery so in
this case we create an animation to show
what we're trying to do is the
foreground is going to move a lot faster
than the background
and if you combine this this together
shine on light true you create a story
in this sense we're creating the
singapore greenery story
and then that was a proof we went on to
find a strong amount of light source and
also a light source that will expand our
this 10 times so that people can see the
image being projected
so we also created a mechanized method
to spin these three days in different
speeds such as have a parallax scrolling
effect
okay we made our first technical hurdle
when we trying to create this graphic on
our
this the first one was i we realized if
we cut vinyl then we will be missing a
lot of details
the next we tried you'll be printing
directly onto the alkaline disk but we
find that there's a lot of color
pigmentation when we
expand this 10 times and we eventually
found this laser etching method at 120
uh dpi 100 1200 dpi and we could cut out
all the details that we required the
last step
we went on
to
place color overlay over these three
disks assemble this
create a tree projection of this and we
hung up on the space of the building
gallery
the next project
is
also in changi airport it's internal one
they were going through a series of
upgrades uh making self-checking
counters and they were going to hold up
this space for a year the client came to
us and asked us what we could do to this
holding rather than have a very cold
space
and and a flat wall
so we work with
a wonderful illustrator esther to come
up with a series of nine windows
very animated windows up which sticks is
interactive
i have a little video to show
what we did so it's about the tourists
as a bird coming to singapore and say
fly through what are the different
sucking sounds that you could see in
singapore
like they fly through and see a
different landscape and
unique buildings of singapore
and fly through santosa or resort island
and they could visit our
residents and what they do day to day
behind the scenes we have a little
graphic to cut out so what we did was we
basically cut out every single detail
put up the pieces and then layer them
eventually to create like a pop-up
effect a 3d effect for every single
window
and then we
went out to mechanized gosh there's this
nine windows we have to mechanize like
this first one is how we use a single
shaft with three different cams to shift
these clouds up and down in different
pace
second one is how we use a rotation
motion to create a sailing boat rocking
back for the effect and the last one we
prototype different
pop-up pickable mechanism
to create this lion popping up
from the bushes
this one so it was a little bit more
complex because this was so small it
couldn't hide our motto so we came up
with a solution of having a 2mm shaft
and give it a single rotation so this is
the primary motion
and from the primary motion we kind of
split it up into secondary motion so if
you
turn this thing around
you could see the single shaft that's
rotating and then how it produces
secondary motion to shift the arm the
upper torso to create this animated
scene
of this two person playing checkers back
and forth
so with all this detail and craft
and effort that we put in
all that we really wanted to do is to
bring people closer together parents
seniors
and then we want to evoke a sense of
wonder a sense of discovery
most importantly we sincerely hope that
as they come singapore they live
singapore they
they will be feeling happy
this latter is the next project which is
also a window to showcase the
up-and-coming shopping experience of a
jewel and wonderful thing about this
shopping experience is there's a 40
meter
rainfall tanks
and there's a lot of trees around this
shopping center so this is like a window
into that space before it was open we
created
interactions
uh
out of these three interactions that
says whistle to me
is a sign on me and then insert coin to
donate
so in the
interaction of whisper to me the
business would have to whistle to the
sensor and then our elephant will kind
of come alive the orangutan will start
to pound the ground
and this is the process of us making we
3d render this thing
3d printed it and then we finish up with
a green moss
next
is we
there's this portion where the user will
shine a torch light and then he will
kind of wick the plants
and the trees
as if you're the sunlight we give
energy to the plants and it starts to
grow
all right
and we use a servo and push rod to kind
of raise and lower the trees okay this
is one shot that's behind the scene
in this single window we have like 40
motors to control uh like things to
control eventually we install two tvs
there to create animation so this is the
role of technologies to tame this beast
and make sure we integrate all these
elements to create a magical moment for
the visitors
okay you can see this is uh pre-covered
times people using their torch light to
shine on our sensor which the tree will
grow
and then on the bottom where some people
couldn't we certainly realized they
would use their hand phone to play a
tune and that would activate our sensor
and then the orangutan the trees is the
elephant is going to be down
eventually we asked people to instacoin
to donate but somehow people feel that
this is like the wishing well they not
only insert coin
they throw a lot of dollar notes
we were surprised but we're happy that
all this is being donated to charity
okay our last uh project is uniqlo
approaches to kind of educate and help
them uh sell terrorism it's a very good
product so t-shirt material that's
cooling spreads uh respiration
quickly and includes a person down we
created two uh solutions for them one is
to create a big t-shirt with
paper windmill around them to show the
coolness of this material and then
second installation we create cloud
pillows for them to help so that people
can know how soft this material is
the team loves it but the marketing
people came back and say
it looks cool
but
are you gonna sell more t-shirts with
that so we were stunned and we were
stuck for a while and out of frustration
i look
at arizona material under a microscope
and then i
realized it's neatly formed weave and if
i sprinkle water it spreads very quickly
and then if i blow on it i realized all
the droplets quickly evaporated there
was this aha moment because i was
surprised this type actually works
so we pitched back to nucleo a solution
so we're gonna
really hang up a cotton t-shirt and an
arrowism and build two robot arms just
to do that we have a microscope at the
end of our arm water sprinkler and a fan
and we could let user choose where to
perspire more and the robot arm will go
to that part of the t-shirt and then
we'll show side by side comparison of
how
terrorism material works against the
cotton and most of time errorism
works perfectly
and then we had this machine this
regular machine built
we couldn't find a robot arm that will
have that tree integrator so we created
our own arms 3d designed our arm 3d
printed rate
research on what motor to use assembly
and then we created our robot house
next the
machine got
drove around in singapore for 20 days
and every single day there was about 200
participants that got to know more about
errorism
and originally nicole kind of picked us
up he wanted us to build machines that
we sent to philippines
malaysia and indonesia
that's all the projects i'm sharing
today i'm happy to have reconnected
uh to my making self
through all these projects
and
it kind of brings me back to a time
where i create contraptions to make my
body slide but now i could make
contraptions and put a smile
on
more people around me
that's all for my presentation thank you
david and and thank you for for
concluding on that note after putting a
smile on the face because as we were
listening to you and and watching
clearly we were smiling and and it is
it's quite a fantastic and magical very
magical moment so thanks sir thanks a
lot for that so now the next speaker so
olivier olivier boss
um
the chief inspiration
officer at mesh9 so can you come on
stage please and i will do a brief
introduction uh about about eulogy so
oliver so he spearheads a creative
technology ideation
from concept to reality and assets with
business strategy at mesh minds so only
interest resolve around exploring the
meaningful intersection between
technology and art and his vast
knowledge of tech trends his usual area
is
usefully aligned with his passion for
using technology for good causes
worldwide so olivier helps to foster an
uplifting environment by creating
meaningful relationships with the people
around him so he works hard to nurture a
genuine
lastic relationship between artists
creative technologies and multinational
organizations to deliver impactful
educational projects and programs so
it's super exciting i can't wait to
listen to you to your presentation so
the floor is yours
please come on stage
super
thank you so much jan and thank you for
having me of course over here
so uh yeah my name is oliver balls uh
you can just say ollie by the way uh
makes it easier so yeah uh i am chief
inspiration officer at mesh minds funky
name um but yeah i'm originally from
amsterdam and almost five years now in
singapore so i'm a tech enthusiast and
really passionate about blending art and
technology together for a sustainable
future and especially during these
exciting new times
all right
so let's talk a bit about who we are as
meshmites so
we are a network of strategists
partnership brokers creators curators
but also program managers and we are
united by a belief that art and
technology can power a sustainable and
inclusive future so we hope to drive
awareness ignite conversations and
inspire behavioral change for the
sustainable development of people and
our planet
all right so
over the last couple of years uh we've
been producing several programs and
campaigns for the world's uh most
responsible companies out there so over
here you see several augmented reality
effects for social media that we made
in-house but also in collaboration with
amazing artists and creators here in
southeast asia
so yeah
what we aim to do is to enable a
metaverse for people and planets
focusing on producing immersive
experiences and educating the public on
what they can do to help and make the
world an even better place for our
future
so
yeah i will bring you through some of
our projects as xr educators as well
well why xr or extended reality so
extended reality is an umbrella term
used to describe immersive technologies
that can merge the physical and virtual
worlds so think of uh ar using your
phone and then you have virtual reality
using a virtual reality headset
so
let me just talk uh talk to you through
about a recent projects and some from
the past
all right here you see art reimagined
korea it just just launched basically
and it's a first of its kind
collaboration in south korea where meta
partnered up with traditional korean
artists and empowering them to give more
people the opportunity to experience
their art through augmented reality and
virtual reality
so we collaborated with the three
traditional artists from south korea we
developed six original ar effects
inspired by the work of the artist so
it's been showcased virtually and
physically over a month-long exhibition
at meta in south korea
so do check it out
all right and here you see please insert
women which was happening in 2021 yeah
and this is world's first creative
technology incubation program uh for
women and non-binary artists in
southeast asia this was in collaboration
with neta porter and we incubated four
singapore based women artists so we
developed with them original ar art
which was inspired by nine attributes of
sustainable fashion and beauty
this also has been showcased virtually
but also physically over a month-long
public exhibition at capella here in
singapore
that is also cool and this is mumu park
this happened in 2021 as well and this
was asia's first drive-through
exhibition powered by hyundai's latest
electric vehicles and spark ar which is
meta's ar development platform so we
collaborated with eight singapore-based
artists and highlighted themes on uh air
pollution and the preservation of our
plants ecological biodiversity where we
had over eight thousand visitors over
two months
uh we engaged over 350 000 people online
with the ar selfie and mural effects and
this was in partnership with the
singapore chinese cultural center and
the united nations environment program
okay here you see please insert human
back all the way in 2019. we did this in
shanghai which is china's first virtual
reality incubation program which was
powered by oculus
so 10 physical visual artists
transformed into vr artists over three
months so we focus on highlighting
chinese culture and folklore and uh
connected artists across geographical
boundaries through remote workshops and
hosted by renowned international via
artists as well
all right
yes and this is meshmine 2.0 art extract
for good which is our second showcase
that we hosted at the art science museum
here in singapore
we developed southeast asia's first
technology incubation program so we
incubated over 20 impact artists and
creative technologists where we
co-produced 20 20-plus immersive
multi-sensory experiences and engaging
over 10 000 visitors in 10 days so it
was also heavily supported by apple and
the united nations environment program
bringing people together learning about
art and technology for good
all right so the previous programs and
experience do resemble uh digital
placemaking somewhat because it's
bringing people together online and
offline so
let's just dive deep into some of the
other projects
that we produced
on this subject
so over here
this is also a while back you'll see
the community threat for singapore
design week in 2019
and it actually started at the national
design center in singapore so here you
see how augmented reality works with
with the video
all right
so it's an immersive ar experience that
brings street art and history to life it
was commissioned by unesco creative
cities in australia and singapore
through sydney city of film and the
project is across this disciplinary
collaboration that featured creatives
from australia and singapore so it's an
ar experience by unesco to revisit the
past and experience murals that come to
life
sadly is not active anymore but it was a
very interactive experience
and also inclusive where you have an ar
wayfinding map and make murals come to
life and also hear about the story of
the mural itself
and narrated by singapore girl
all right there's another video which is
sustainable singapore 2020 uh that we
produced in reaction to the start of the
pandemic so over here you see people
interacting with uh
ar art powered by artify which is also
an ar platform it's a very cool tool so
do check it out where you can make your
art come to life
and it has been toured around quite a
lot already this exhibition it's both
online and offline
so
we basically empower 20 of the best and
emerging established artists from
singapore to produce original ar
artworks on the theme of sustainable
singapore and the sustainable
development goals using artifive so five
of these artworks have been selected for
a permanent exhibition as well at the
national forest museum in korea so
together with artifice it also had
exhibitions and toured around galleries
and shows in austria
korea and germany and could be also be
experienced just on your laptop
on a virtual microsite
ah cool this is art our art trail which
happened in 2020 um
so there was also during singapore art
week we had singapore's first public art
walking trail which was powered by metas
spark ar that augments
six sculptures by local pioneer artists
using digital placemaking technology so
we collaborated with these six local
pioneer artists which was in partnership
with the national arts council empowered
by sparky our from metal
so you see two examples of the six ar
effects that we produced here
on the left you see the time tree by
robert sal with its ar effect that we
produced
and then on the right you see kumari
nahapan's pembengan which is a 45 meter
large bronze sculpture which is actually
the largest bronze sculpture in
singapore that we augmented and extended
the narrative of nahapan's interest in
representing local flora and fauna so
the movement in the ar effect signifies
the trade coming from the bay into the
city of florida
all right then we came back with art
trill this year but now in transit which
was on the mrt lines so in collaboration
with lta
nac and the meta open arts
it invited people to look at existing
art
found at six downtown line stations
through augmented reality right so we
collaborate with four local artists and
students from nafa and lasalle where we
created 12 unique ar effects across six
mrt stations in the downtown
on the downtown line so it was part of a
10-day exhibition during this year
singapore art week and some are still
out there so you can check them out how
we reimagined art
on the downtown lives and transformed it
into augmented reality effects that you
could easily share with your friends and
family across the globe
yeah we also collaborated with uniclow
and here you see shockscape was very
cool
which is an interactive ar mural for
uniqlo um in singapore in celebration of
national day 2021.
shockscape also celebrates and brings
the life singapore's famous hawker
culture
all right
so we collaborate the artist eight eight
spud and when you scan the artwork in
the store you learn about singapore's
agriculture in an interactive and
playful way where you get a little quiz
and therefore also in the end you can
turn around the camera and take a selfie
with their art as well
all right so now i've brain dumped you
with what we do and what we've done with
our experiment experience project right
so now it's time to think a bit about
the future and such as the metaverse or
a metaverse which i just mentioned
so
thinking what's next are we going to
experience new ways of
coming together using technology being
more immersed
or
how we can enjoy our together crossing
borders in an immersive way or will it
be a blend between digital and the
physical worlds
jury's still out we don't know but we
are here to make sure to preserve our
cultural heritage as a driver for
sustainability using technology for
people and planner
all right so thank you so much everyone
thanks for listening and um yeah also
here virtually do check us out on
meshmines.com and follow us on meshmines
and yeah hope to catch you guys online
and maybe here around in singapore
thank you
thank you very much ollie it's really uh
inspiring to see the projects and and
how the digital how you're bringing sort
of uh the artistic aspect into uh you
know into sort of the next level of
connecting um artists and technology
um so thank you very much
so
our next speaker last but certainly not
least uh from canada joining us all the
way from canada uh it's
cheryl catterl creative director of
moment factory so women factory has been
active in singapore as well so we wanted
to invite cheryl to speak to uh to our
audiences um to share with about her
projects and her career so her career
spans 25 years and
she has specialized in heading up
multi-disciplinary teams to deliver high
impact experiences with a particular
focus of integration of new media
technologies into architectural and also
public space design
so drawing on her professional degree in
architecture um and this certificate in
set and costume design her career has
really followed the path leading from
installation and performing arts to
immersive exhibition design and the
creation of multimedia experiences for
permanent contemporary installations in
both institutional and corporate
settings her passion is the design of
responsive environments where digital
engagement is seamlessly woven into
architectural and citizen contexts so
without further ado cheryl please take
it away
all right um
thank you so um
as as ola said i did start out my life
as an architect um i quickly veered over
into the performing arts and like david
i'm an early adopter i was using
multimedia technology in starting the
late 90s um so i've grown up with this
through my career and uh here i am a
number of years later talking to you
about uh digital placemaking so as i was
preparing for this conference i i
thought let's start from a
standing point and i looked at
what is placemaking how do we define it
so out of the seven million results that
google gave me um
the one that i like best is that place
making is a process it's a means to an
end and the create creation of quality
places so i'll go through this a little
bit more and how how i see this but
the next step is to talk about how this
definition can extend out to digital
place making so often when we talk about
digital place
we talk about portable digital devices
that sort of unearth stories about a
place and uh while this is interesting
and then one facet of digital
placemaking i think it's a bit limited
because it's for me what gets me excited
is about bringing people together and
sharing around public spaces
so to start about i think let's start
about what it's not before we start
defining what it is so a lot of people
feel that digital in the public sphere
is very aggressive and market driven um
and while this is true i like to go back
to kind of basics and when we talk about
public spaces go back to aldo rossi
so he says that one can say that the
city itself is the collective memory of
its people and like memory it's
associated with objects and places the
city is the locus of the collective
memory so um
while while you're thinking about this
we'll touch on this later but look at
the photo in the background it's uh the
jacquez bridge in montreal the city
where i live and taken around the turn
of the 19th century we're going to get
back to this and then how do you invest
a memory um how do you invest a monument
over and over as collective memory
shifts
so let's go back even further before
cities existed and start talking about
the campfire um i had an experience
working with the cree which is the an
indigenous community in northern canada
and uh we're working on an
archaeological project they're a nomadic
culture that sort of follows the animals
around during the hunting seasons but
they found that uh remains of fires that
were at the same place over thousands
and thousands of years so for me it's
not about the city it's not about like
objects like rossi said but it's really
where the places where we tell our
stories
so i'm going to start off by talking
what is a digital campfire by using a
singaporean example
so this is uh shanghai experiences
theater of experience this is a moment
factory project
in the waiting areas at the airport and
what's interesting it's a kind of
illusion between digital and
digital and physical and at one point
what appears to be architecture opens up
and lets you into the intimacy of a
singaporean household's living room so
what's really great about this is it
brings together people who don't know
singaporean culture but also
singaporeans who sort of feel a sense of
warmth or nostalgia about stories they
might already know
i feel that this is a bit limited though
this notion of the digital campfire
so let's talk back about creative
processes because i think place making
for me is a process and not
not a result so the creative process
behind multimedia and i'll use the word
multimedia placemaking instead of
digital because as we're getting into
the metaverse i believe it's more
encompassing so it invigorates and
reinvests our common spaces with
evolving and culturally rich narratives
it augments physical public space with
real-time digital experience that foster
a collective sense of belonging
so going back to the bridge this is a
project where a number of creative
companies in montreal collaborated
together to actually bring a digital
layer onto the jacquard say bridge which
is one of the main icons of the city of
montreal you can't see a montreal
t-shirt that doesn't uh that doesn't
show this
so it's it's a kind of double
intervention one which is projected
lighting which is a storytelling
that shifts with the seasons and the
other one is a interactive layer that's
um
activated by a hashtag so there's led
lights on the side that become more
active or less active as people are
engaged and what's really interesting
about this project is also the system
that allows us to uh sort of bring bring
to the forefront um and be very reactive
to what's actually going on in current
events
so uh we were asked moment factory was
asked
to
bring hope to the face of in in the face
of pandemic during the uh obviously
during the pandemic when we were all in
lockdown and actually couldn't get out
so for us here in canada the rainbow is
the symbol of hope and resilience in
face of the pandemic so uh when we go
back to the social media question that
was asked earlier people actually
weren't going out in the space to see it
but it became very popular on social
media and a way of sharing this common
reality that we're all living through
and still are living through right now
so getting back to covid obviously our
habits have significantly changed and um
how do you start putting to place
digital place making when no model
exists anymore we don't know how people
are going to react when you go back into
space we don't know how
this this hybrid life that we've had in
the last two years is going to play out
so um
so i'm going to propose a kind of system
of how we can work a process
as you will to reinvest our public
spaces and bring people back and
connecting together
i'm going to show an example of this is
a project that was done obviously before
pandemic but at banff national park
where the digital technology was
actually portable technology there were
groups of ten that each had a piece of
of technology and as they went on a trek
um they each participated and brought
out different parts of the story as they
moved through the space of the park so
you don't need this large infrastructure
for instance the jacques carty bridge
project was a 30 million dollar project
um and nobody's willing to put that kind
of money in right now i think as we do
as there's so much uncertainty but you
can do it quite simply and you can
achieve the same results
um so i just threw up a little bit of a
model i'll go through some projects that
that respect that um sort of express
this later but to me it's all about
generating shared benefits and value and
if we do it in an agile fashion and
obviously when we work in digital
technologies we work in a very agile way
it's not a kind of waterfall
way of working but if you create a spark
bring people back
measure it using digital technologies
allows us to collect data and measure
engagement and sort of
see what works what doesn't work and
then that allows it to scale us it up
and to build it and to evolve the
projects that we've already established
next
so
multimedia placemaking in this context
offers a unique means to connect
citizens places and systems in real time
this approach fosters adaptable
alliances that maximize shared value
rallying multiple stakeholders and we
talk about stakeholders we talk about
the communities but we also talk about
the people the funding instances and the
governments that are putting in place
these means for us to reconnect together
so um let's put it on to the next slide
and i'll i'll um talk a little bit of
about stakeholders so for those of us
who've worked in the public realm you
understand that there's enormous amounts
of bees sort of buzzing around uh the
honeypot and we have to find ways of
saying what's a shared value to me it's
about this process that allows us to
sort of understand each other and work
together but also having a strong
creative vision that drives us together
and drives us in the same line to
amplify social purpose and to create
common value both of these things then
foster reputational value and contribute
to earned media value which obviously
feeds back to the business community and
to the government and brings value to
them so that we're all working together
towards the same ends
um again this is all about feasibility
um and and how we get people together to
work uh
and have different facets that
contribute to society on a greater level
both for the audiences that is
experiencing these um these
interventions and for the people that
are are funding it and supporting it and
structuring it such as our governments
so i'm going to go through a number of
different projects that show different
ways that this can be done and at the
end it becomes i guess a toolbox of of
what is digital placemaking and what is
multimedia placemaking i'm going to
start with this project which is
actually a hybrid project done during
the
pandemic it's a yearly project
as a commemoration for a mass
killing that occurred in montreal and in
this year for the first time the public
wasn't allowed to be there it was hybrid
there was a facebook live um but the uh
government officials were there the
elected officials were there and what's
really interesting is it became a
communal event where people participated
in facebook it could be seen it was
obviously very shareable but then it
became something where the politicians
were there as well and there were people
there um live
another thing is there's a permanent
infrastructure in montreal that allows
for projection large-scale projection
mapping but then uh this is a project
where we brought in obviously containers
and a smaller projector and a microphone
where people were given a voice so this
is a very exclusive um
activity about bringing people into the
public sphere giving them a voice and
then we connected to the larger scale
projectors that were
actually interpreting the system was
interpreting what was being said and
reprojecting it larger on the other
building that you don't see in this
picture but uh what's interesting again
it just gives a larger resonance to sort
of bringing people together and taking a
voice in public
um the other thing that you can do is
you can invest uh construction sites
this was a light rail uh construction
site that was actually late it was gonna
be delivered late and so we created a um
we created a kind of walk-through of the
space using projection using lighting
using interactive mediums to bring the
space to life
um this is a project done with the
windsor art gallery and it's bringing
art out into the streets within the city
there's a whole uh journey that you can
do there's an app that allows you to
interact and to engage directly with the
different art pieces and the innovation
that each of these art pieces
expresses and then it drives people back
to the art gallery people who might not
have seen the art gal who might not go
to the art gallery otherwise and it
brings it out to a much larger public
uh 18d discovery whole different scale
uh att obviously a public company uh
that inve a private company that
invested in a large public space a
number of different canvases the large
screen a band stand
lighting in the fountain and a kind of
pergola over people's heads um so this
is really interesting place making
because it is privately funded but it's
really giving back to the community and
giving a place to the community and then
um and then we've layered on to it
recently and integrated a new element
which is a kind of uh responsive uh
backdrop uh they hold a lot of musical
events here so it's basically a program
that allows the different types of music
be it uh you know r b or hip hop or jazz
or pop music to generate images through
the rhythm of the music and create a
backdrop that radiates out throughout
the overall um the overall space and
creates a kind of virtual set design
olivia already talked about ar but how
do you create a landmark which is a sofi
stadium in los angeles and create an
enhanced experience through
the use of
ar and augmented reality
and to finish up i'm going to go back to
the bridge um for those who don't know
uh in canada we had a system of
residential schools where uh this is in
the last century where children in
indigenous communities were actually
taken away from their families
to be you know brainwashed i guess in
into adopting
adopting either english or french
culture instead of their own cultures
and um we've there we found um at one
point there was found some the remains
of a number of children that were
unexplained around the sites of these
residential schools and so what happened
is all of the mass across the country
went um at half mass for a significant
period of time
and the bridge itself and the society
that runs the bridge decided to develop
what they call the the kind of half mast
mode for the bridge which allows it to
uh respect mourning and respect
difficult situations and so to sort of
wrap up when we talk about digital
placemaking or multimedia placemaking
for me it's about the stories that are
being telled it's about what we're
communicating it's not necessarily about
the technology and sometimes the less
technology the lesser technology is the
best technology um there is
so thank you so much and i can't wait to
look i'm looking very much forward to
the questions
thank you thank you so much uh cherie it
was uh fascinating to to to listen to
you and and uh you could have continued
on and on it was um almost um like uh
like a course on
uh digital placemaking so thanks a lot
for sharing with us your
your processes and all of your ideas
behind the digital placemaking so i will
now
ask the the all of the speakers to come
back on stage uh and so we started our q
and a we received quite um quite a fair
bit of um
of questions uh already so um so we we
will take them on but before embarking
on that just to thank once again
david olivier and cheryl for
sharing your journey your creative
process your ideas and this represents
how diverse is digital place making from
making crafting creating
really those objects mesmerizing object
all the way to
augmented reality metaverse and so on
and finally to really go back to as you
mentioned and
in in in one of your slides on cheril it
is
um the process not the result it's
really the process that matters that
matters the most in digital place making
and also to reflect the pulse of the
city
and that's fascinating so that's what
we'll be talking about as well so
maybe we can take on some of the
questions
that we and
i see them like continuing arriving
so we will start with david um so uh so
thanks again for sharing your experience
so
like we noticed whimsical thread across
your work so where do you get your
inspiration from
wow
whimsical
can i can i share some things which i
didn't share earlier
i was involved in web one and did a lot
of interactive stuff i surprisingly went
further on in into the years probably
into my eighth year i felt a little bit
jaded because i felt whatever i was
doing lives inside the screen
only
and i'm wanting so much to leave outside
that screen so i
i gave myself a mission it's like could
i do the same thing without the screen
at all
and hence you see
the all the interpretations of the
insert coin stuff is they were done
without a stream so i was asking myself
can i create animation if there's no
screen so what do i have to do i have to
learn about mechanization pick up motto
how should i shift things and move them
around so i didn't realize that once i
hated that direction it opens an
entirely new view
so having say that some of the
things that you see that with musical
they are not
probably not directly
uh inspired by creative
uh
direction but they're actually
inspired by a technological direction
for example there are certain sensors
that can do a special thing like the
light sensor that you see the people
bring the torch so we we discovered that
sensor so we're thinking
how can we use it in a creative manner
and create a magical moment for our
users for our visitors
okay okay thanks thanks for for sharing
and and also like to go back a little
bit also on your own
history and how how did you start on all
of that so then thanks again david so we
have another question yes okay this this
question would be uh for ali um so we've
seen a lot of um a lot of uh kind of
your work with a lot of artists and you
really are connecting sort of the
technological aspects uh with the more
creative aspects so working technology
and culture um working together so what
is your approach uh to the project
obviously there's there's so much
diversity and very different clients
that you work with um so is the
different uh is is that is it
different when the end goal is to
educate um as opposed to your some other
clients where
there are more commercial projects and
how would you how would you
differentiate between or would you
oh interesting question because if you
if you look at it the end goal
is to educate which is mainly what we
want to do is to educate with our
projects right we're not looking at
commercial kind of projects at all what
we really may need to do is to educate
and inspire people with our projects and
our approach
um to it it really starts with research
right you need to understand the overall
scope everything what it's about all the
ins and outs and the effects of it in
order to educate properly and dive into
that subject also together with the
artists for example and hard-hitting uh
problems in the world like the plastic
pollution crisis you need to understand
where it comes from
and therefore i think research is key
therefore um to start off with but yeah
if you if my personal opinion when i
compare it with the commercial projects
in the end you kind of want to educate
the people as well if you work on a
commercial project right
in terms of educating why you should buy
something so it does intertwine with it
but with us
with our approach it's really research
and we ideate and we refine the concepts
and also test right
that's if it leaves an impact because
that's the most important part that we
want to do
with our projects is to leave an impact
so that it's memorable memorable that
you have a key takeaways with it and
whereas with commercial projects is more
the key takeaway is by this product
for example our key takeaways is a take
action take action in terms of maybe its
behavioral change uh instead of choosing
a plastic bottle grab your use your
reusable one everywhere you go um
and that is by reinforcing the
educational factor is by understanding
the subject the best
i think that's our the main approach
that i also like to take is just to
research research research and therefore
test test tests as well in order to see
if you get to the right approach and if
the key takeaways are
really taken for granted into
consideration
and people's behavior mainly
and to inspire
yeah i think i think it's important but
what you mentioned to um
to make an impact
to make something memorable and that
people will remember and that we'll
share and that we really like
leave a trace so from that i would like
to to ask
a question to to share him um since
we're talking about like
making an impact so how
can we make digital experiences more
inclusive
and and on that you feel that it leaves
some people behind because if we talk
about making an impact if you talk about
digital experiences for the ones that
are not in digital experience of digital
the world
will we leave them behind so how do you
how do you look into that
well i i feel like um
you know
as some of the projects that i presented
uh yes you would need some kind of
digital tool but not not the majority of
them and if i look at like it's a lot
about bringing bringing stories to
public spaces and animating and
activating public spaces and i feel like
if i look at what's happening in
the discussions we're having right now
if you think back
on all of these stakeholders people are
collaborating together like we're
putting together
government-funded projects that are
asking for private intervention or
private spaces
and then working very closely with
community groups to build these projects
and make sure that they're reaching the
audiences i think you know again when we
go back to the process i think that i
this is what i'm really seeing right now
um and i i think as long as we're
bringing these um
like we're less we're less about uh
we're about multi-media entertainment
and getting people to have an impact and
to understand things and to be excited
and to have fun together and to get back
together and i feel like as long as
we're activating the public space and we
have the right people around the table
then we're as inclusive as possible and
i think um
one thing that's important is that
you're intervening at different scales
it's not just through the phone but it's
walking around it's looking at new
things like if you look at the art
gallery project um in the streets the
phone brings you a different experience
but you can also experience it other in
in other ways without having
the phone and it gets you to know your
city it gets you to know the artists and
it gets you hopefully visiting the
museum and bringing greater community
value
yes it's really
looking back into the built environment
and to see how digital solutions can be
implemented inside so it is not just
basically a phone or like a digital
companion but it is more so how digital
solutions can be inserted in the built
environment for people to interact
perhaps in a low tech way although it is
backed up by digital solutions so you
have another question it's very
interesting because we see the
resonating uh sort of uh threat in in
all of your uh works uh
because contrary to what my people some
people might think digital uh you you uh
you all are bringing uh
people together it's not it's it does
not become an isolating tool but uh
uh you know it is becoming a tool that
connects people to places and with one
another so
on that note it's a question to all
three speakers um
perhaps getting uh perspective from all
three of you what are some of the
challenges that you have been facing
when working with digital environments
and do you think that uh digital
can recreate
physical experiences or do you feel that
there's still
some
physical experiences that cannot be
replicated and how can digital and
physical
reconcile with that
i think we'll start with uh david yes
okay
a good question a
i think
for our work against a coin we kind of
reconcile digital and physical
and that's where i was saying uh maybe i
should stop the screen
part and
make things alive and be first
and such that we can move this to public
spaces
okay okay
great thank you thank you david
what about you uh and what do you what
is your perspective
yeah so so the challenges right that you
face with technology sometimes sometimes
technology breaks as well and we're
working with also with frontier
technology
which sometimes it doesn't work always
and we have to be compliant with that
it's not like oh it's it's not working
it's it's a
experience
but these are certain challenges as well
also with um which cheryl touched upon
as well with with inclusiveness right
how to make it as inclusive as possible
is how we think it is well with other
minority groups where mabel uh are
unable to experience certain things so
we try to think
in our approach with certain projects as
well how can we make it as exclusive as
possible
with the ar experience that we produce
it needs to also be run in in
countries where the internet speed is
maybe very low and that they can't
access it uh very well so the experience
needs to be very uh easy accessible in
that way in uh
that sense but to also answer the
question about the physical uh and the
digital environment right i got very
inspired by this this youtuber who spent
two weeks long in virtual reality
completely isolated
two weeks he gets a reality four weeks
you're doing everything you can do
but he did his meditation he did his
meetings he still connected with other
people in a different way and still
seeing other people
but most interesting part uh his
takeaway from it was like
he missed the natural connection that
something digital could never
replicate that certain almost like a
sixth sense that that humans may have
when they meet with it with each other
physically that is something that as
human connections could never uh the
digital environments can never replicate
is that uh the the smell of nature right
that really that's that smell and that
feeling you have to work with with
nature and connections you have and you
build up with the people around you i
think that is going to be a very tough
part uh
going forward but we must never forget
to always connect with the real world
and not let let's see technology as a
tool right something to help us to aid
us with and not to replace certain
things
but really to help us and uh not to
replace
yeah but thank you thanks for for
showing your view and sharing on your
hand what do you think of all of that
um well i think i'll touch on both
questions at the same time uh one of the
challenges especially during the
pandemic is when we're working with
digital tools we get disconnected from
the physical and and we stay in our head
and we're creating within our head um
whereas at moment factory like our our
tagline is we do it in public it's all
about bringing people together and
bringing people to connect so it's um
bringing people like out in the space
like alivia said it's it's about it's
about the smells it's about the wind
it's about walking through space
movements are really part a big part of
public space right that when you're in
the screen you don't have that so
um i think you
we think about is the digital is one of
many tools but like you say um like you
see in the jacquardia project it's you
know toning down has a bigger message
toning down the digital has a bigger
message as not
and
the digital is just a tool to bring
people together so it's one of many
pieces including the public realm
including the space and the architecture
that that we play with
um so we just have to be really careful
to keep the balance
yeah yeah but on that night it's
interesting because we've been
experiencing a pandemic
for two years and is it still happening
it's not as if it is like suddenly gone
is still there and so um digital place
making and all of these questions about
will digital platform replace basically
the reality and sort of the virtual
reality even more now metaverse is
ramping up so so these are our true
questions from our audience from all of
us on
like
what is what will digital world replace
the the real world and some on that
um like
the question that that we have from the
audience as well
it is how the dependency
has changed your way
of
creating of engaging
and
basically performing all of these
digital
placemaking so so that that is something
that is
quite strong what has happened so
maybe they're homes to take on that
question but
how the pandemic has changed your way of
creating towards digitally speaking
well
i'm sorry if i can take this question
right it's it's
more uh if you look at the pandemic
people were separated you couldn't see
your loved ones you couldn't come
together in a safe way because what we
try to reimagine then is okay instead of
bringing people physically to a certain
place you could also bring them
closer together virtually which is then
the best alternative right to cross
borders basically
so
i'll go back in what inspired me to
really
focus on using tech for good and back in
amsterdam and i developed this concept
called time to travel vr where we
developed the concept uh based on the
ide ideo design mythology uh to design
and experience um whatever experience
could be um for and we chose the the
group um immobile elderly people and
during our research we noticed that they
were just wanted to go out to be happy
again but they couldn't go out so how
can you
make them go out and that was through
technology with virtual reality so then
we design an experience
very highly curated to the to that
audience to elderly people and
transported into new cities
and
relived memories again
therefore and saw that like they left
relive memories from bringing an old
lady who couldn't move anymore back to
london and then when we tested it out
with her she took it off and i start and
i see her cry and
what about i knew you were saying that
are you okay he said yeah well that's
that's that's where my life started
basically and i couldn't never go be
there so in light of the pandemic
bringing it back right it's
trying to find that's what humans do
we're trying to find the best way
possible to reconnect in certain ways
um and which also has a positive impact
i mean the the sustainable singapore
exhibition that we launched was
first of all just
to be online and therefore okay has been
shown online worldwide but then it's
been also been shown physically
in uh other parts of the world in korea
in austria singapore art is being
represented in austria which is a great
venture
from starting from something that sounds
so horrible like a pandemic
and then finding the solution to react
to it in both a physical and
a
virtual way
to still keep on bringing together
because that's also the core business of
digital placemaking is enhancing that
experience and how to bring them
together
right
thanks a lot
because i see that at the time we run
so we'll ask the ones that i think most
people or at least
we would love to know more about so i
think um ollie you spoke about like i
guess
um
connecting sort of the
different types of audience of all their
audiences um
to to
to memories to places using sometimes
digital technologies so i guess there
will be also a question to everyone do
you um
uh of course technologies can be made
obsolete do you how do you ensure that
people
people connect to um to the experiences
and then um the technology is is not
sort of becomes a a product that becomes
obsolete in a few years how do you how
do you
up with all of continue and uh like
maybe it's the question if we can
have to to share it because the moment
factory is like
like even developing new technology so
how do you keep up with all of that you
know like to be always like you know on
the data holder that you take and to
make sure that people are also uh you
know it doesn't go over their heads
um i think you know it's always about
the experience we're trying to create
and and the connections we're trying to
we're trying to encourage um
we have a lab so we were trying to be
ahead of the curve by by testing things
out ahead of time so that when it gets
delivered to uh one of our clients or
one of our collaborators we know it's
good for a certain period of time um
we also really invest heavily in the
system it's it's the driver that's
important and then you can add on and
evolve and change and and
scale up the interventions uh as opposed
to just saying here's one solution
here's one experience and it doesn't
change because when when we go in
especially in the permanent projects
that we do we're there for the long haul
and and so i think i think it's that and
and
um
ensure that it's easy to fix it's easy
to update it's easy to change if it
needs to be um but you know our one of
our first projects uh los angeles
airport's been there almost uh almost 10
years now and it's still running fine so
yeah
and i i will have one one last question
for for david um and uh because it's
always a burning question for from our
audience um you you did so many things
you explore so many things and the level
of creativity is fascinating
and when you mix basically low-tech
solution associated with a high tech as
well digital solutions and so on
what would be your your advice to a
young designer that would be keen to
explore similar fields
come and join me
that's easy
i i think
you will have to be very open like in my
career i have to change track
and then start asking questions if i
don't use this track what other tech can
i replace with oh can i go very low tech
like in my in my case and then there's
somehow something open a new view for me
so be open-minded
try different things and then don't
worry to fail i feel much and you you
learn faster so
i'm just showing you the nice side of
the project but there are
many iterations we have to go through
failures with the phase and how we come
back up in and do a better job next time
so that's my advice for
young people coming in
be open
and be courageous
thanks a lot we saw some more questions
arriving they will be answered offline
so they will be shared with with our
audience so so no worries on that
on that front and
before we head over to design singapore
to share a last addressing message to
our audience we are once again to to
thank so much our speakers david olivier
sharing it was inspiring it was
fascinating like you transported us
like i don't want to save the metagross
okay the transported has
come to a digital platform and we were
with you in all of your experiences we
were with you in in when you are
fabricating exploring crafting all of
these experiencing experiences so it was
very exciting um we
uh we don't know if there will be a
possible collaboration between the three
of you which was one of the questions
let's see let's see what the future will
offer us
so maybe that will happen we don't know
so that would be also fantastic
and i think what we've seen that's very
inspiring today is seeing how digital
technologies are meant to connect people
to places and i think that's that's
basically the resonating thought with
all of us uh today and hopefully this is
where um
digital place making is going it's
really um it's really not disconnecting
people from the physical but creating um
that those connections uh with people
with places and
with one another so
yeah
so i think yeah i think we're just
and again like it's exactly what we do
at scgd what we believe in uh at segd um
so uh so that is kind of experiencing
experiences and to nurture also the next
generation to learn from each other to
continue creating and you can really see
that with the three speakers today and
that's what we really love doing with
hola
through our scgd platform yes so stay
tuned for your events
[Music]
for joining us today once again and for
sharing your insights with us and to you
our attendees thank you for joining us
till the end of the session we hope that
you've learned something new today so
before you go we would really appreciate
if you could take some time to share
your feedback with us through a quick
survey by scanning the qr code that you
see on the left a link to the survey can
also be found in the zoom chat right
about now
and also if you'd like to find out more
programs that are happening at the
national design center you can scan the
qr code that you see on the right so
this is where we'll all leave you now
thank you all once again for joining us
and we hope to see you at our future
events take care and goodbye